SCOTT: Hi everyone, and welcome
to our talk on taking
advantage of Android
platform features.
I'm Scott, and this is Vikram.
And we're both engineers who
work on Android applications.
VIKRAM: Right.
So let's start with who the
intended audience is, who we
think you are, and what you
should gain out of this talk.
This stock is aimed at
intermediate Android
developers.
I know it says advanced But
it's all right if you're
intermediate.
This is not an introductory
talk.
We're hoping that you are
developers who have an
application on the Play Store.
You have features that you
hope to implement.
You have some bugs.
Probably not you guys--
I can tell you guys don't
have many, many bugs.
We got some bugs.
But for developers like you,
two big goals stand out.
The first goal is to improve
your consumer experience.
Consumers like applications
that are well behaved.
They like applications that
are responsive and smooth,
applications that work
well on the system,
consume less battery.
And the second is to improve
your own productivity.
You can implement features
faster, and you can squash
bugs quicker if you can
work faster yourself.
So if you can do those two
things, that allows you to
make apps that invite
more users.
And so you get more money.
And that keeps you in business
SCOTT: I think that slide still
has too many words.
We were told to reduce
bullets.
VIKRAM: Yeah, when were going
through this, they kept
telling us, cut down
on bullets.
So we have a special
slide for you guys.
If this doesn't fit the
bill, you're probably
in the wrong room.
OK, wow.
Nobody left, good.
So a little bit about us.
We wrote the Gmail app.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT: That's not
entirely true.
It wasn't just the two of us.
There are others.
VIKRAM: Yeah, you're right.
We have to be honest
in this crowd.
We wrote Gmail along with many
other qualified engineers.
SCOTT: Keep going.
VIKRAM: OK, this is
a tough crowd.
We wrote Gmail.
We're in a smaller team.
And we're the only ones
who are free.
No--
SCOTT: We are engineers
on Gmail.
VIKRAM: We're engineers
We have a big team.
We also have a lot of users.
Gmail and email is used by
over 100 million users.
Think about that for a minute
a bug that impacts 1% of our
pocket still impact over
a million people.
So squashing bugs is
a big deal for us.
We also need to constantly
improve the user experience.
Mobile moves really fast.
People expect features.
And the speed of iteration
is critical
to every app's success.
It's clear that it's critical
to your app's success, too.
So hopefully, you can
take something
out of our best practices.
Perhaps, applied to your app,
it might help in improving
your lives.
Our overall approach
is to rely on the
framework very heavily.
The more that the framework
does, the less
that we have to do.
This means that the complexity
in our code base is reduced.
And this allows us to iterate
faster, to iterate on features
faster, to squash
bugs quicker.
And this is a reinforcing
cycle because the lesser
complex your code is,
the quicker you
can iterate on features.
And if you rely on the framework
for those features,
you can iterate even
faster the next
feature that comes along.
So a great way to reduce
complexity in your course is
to modularize your
UI components.
And the way we do this is to
modularize our visual elements
into fragments.
Gmail and email use fragments
extensively.
We have the same code that runs
on phone and on tablet,
and we use XML resources to
give you the right layout.
Here's an example
of this pattern.
On the top half, above that
horizontal line, you can see
an example of the layout
that we use on phone.
It's a fragment that's specified
right in the XML.
It's a list fragment.
And it's the same list fragment
that we use on tablets.
The tablet XML is the bottom
half of that slide.
And on tablet, since we have
more real estate, we can put
two fragments side by side.
And so we have a linear layout
with a list fragment and a
content fragment.
Having these sort reusable
components allows you to take
advantage of framework features
fairly rapidly.
So earlier this year, there
was this big framework
feature, a big new feature that
we wanted to implement.
And we had an intern do it for
us because, even though he was
new to the code, the code was
already quite modular.
And so he was able to implement
this all on his own.
I mean, talk about impact.
That was pretty impressive.
SCOTT: Yeah, I wish
he was still here.
He'd probably give a better
talk than us.
VIKRAM: Yeah, that's true.
He was quite something.
We learned a lot when
he was here.
We learned a lot about how
to handle fragments.
So let's talk about
that for a minute.
First, we do very little in
the fragments constructor.
We perform all of our
initialization in the
fragment's life cycle methods.
And we don't maintain any
pointers because pointers
don't last well because the
activities life cycle is very
different from the fragments
life cycle.
And so pointers will gets stale,
so we don't maintain
any of those.
That's a lot sort of
separate ideas.
Let's look at them
in isolation.
This is the general pattern
we use for a fragment.
As you see, it has a single
variables, called state, it's
a parcelable.
And it's not initialized
in the constructor.
Actually, we do nothing
That's secret Google code.
We don't do anything
in the constructor.
This means that you need to
get that state somehow.
And we get it through
arguments.
We get it in the onCreate
method, where there's a
fragment method called
getArguments.
And we have a string tag
called ARG_STATE.
The string could be anything.
But you get that parcelable.
And you assign it in onCreate.
This means that you have to
express your state as
parcelables because, if it's a
native Java type, you're OK.
But if it's not native, if it's
not an int or something,
you have to express it
as a parcelable.
But that turns out to be a good
thing to do because if
you can express your state in
terms of parcelables, then you
can pass it through Intents.
You can give it to
other activities.
So these kinds of patterns
lead to other
benefits down the road.
So you might wonder how we
construct these fragments.
This is the pattern that we use
for constructing all of
our fragments.
We have a static new instance
method for every
fragment that we use.
And in this case, since there
was a single state variable,
we pass it to the new
instance method.
I see a couple of people
taking pictures.
Don't worry, all of
this is there in--
we have a sample app to explain
some of the stuff.
So you don't need to get
any of these slides.
But it's nice that you are.
You could probably take pictures
of us while you're
doing that.
[LAUGHTER]
VIKRAM: So that's how we
get all of the state.
At this point, you're probably
wondering what happens to the
pointers that you're
passing around?
SCOTT: Not really.
I'm wondering how I'll
remember any of this.
VIKRAM: OK, yeah this shouldn't
be like school.
Like I mentioned earlier,
if you can't
remember any of this stuff--
I have a terrible memory.
We have a sample app with
many of these ideas
that you can download.
And you can see how
we do this.
SCOTT: Just the app?
VIKRAM: Just the sample app.
Yeah-- oh yeah, source code.
OK, we'll post source code along
with the sample app.
Because the sample app itself
might not be useful.
So that will be at the
end of the talk.
So this is how we get
you guys to stay the
entire 40 minute duration.
Where was I?
SCOTT: Pointers.
VIKRAM: Pointers,
right pointers.
So you might be wondering, if I
have pointers going back and
forth, how exactly
do I manage that?
That gets tricky with the
decoupled life cycle of the
activity and the fragment
because you don't really know
when a fragment will come in,
and when it'll go out.
And so, for things like that,
we use a very light coupling
between those two.
So I'll talk about that in
a little bit from now.
But let's go into the
empty constructor.
You might wonder why you need
an empty constructor?
This is a question we get
quite frequently.
As you can see in this graph,
you're interface to creating
this fragment is this new
instance method, which goes in
and calls the empty constructor
for you.
When you rotate the device, the
fragment manager will call
the empty constructor
on your behalf.
And it will populated it with
those arguments that you had
set earlier.
And then, when you rotate it
again, it will call your empty
constructor again.
And so this is going on for
the fragments anyway.
And you might want to leverage
that because the fragment
manager is doing it for you.
So this takes the burden
out of your hands.
Once the arguments are set, it
will stay with the fragment.
So the framework even says so.
It says, every fragment needs
an empty constructor
SCOTT: Does it actually
say that?
VIKRAM: That's a screen grab.
It actually says that
on the documents.
So make an empty constructor.
You need an empty constructor.
Leverage it.
Use it to your benefit.
So I mentioned earlier about a
coupling pattern between a
fragment and an activity.
This is the general idea.
On the left, there's a fragment,
which implements
this interface called
action taker.
And when the activity is
created, it registers itself
with the controller.
The activity implements the
controller, and it allows for
a fragment to register
with it.
And at some point in the future,
when the activity
needs to take an action, it
delegates that to the fragment.
Let's take a look at
some real code.
Here you can see the activity.
The activity implements an
interface which allows the
fragment to register
with the activity.
When the activity needs to
perform something, it checks
if a listener has been
registered previously.
Because if a listener hasn't
been registered, there is
nothing to do, right?
Because you don't have a
delegate to handle it.
You just drop it on the floor.
This technique works really
well because these
implementations are not
tied to a fragment.
You could move this
implementation to a view, or
to another activity, or
through an intent.
And so the delegate object can
really be of any type.
It doesn't have to
be a fragment.
More importantly, you could have
many fragments do this.
In this example, we have a
single delegate object because
this is similar to what we use
in Gmail, where you have a
single list activity.
But you could have
many of these.
You could have five or six
different fragment, all of
which need to update if they
have registered with the
controller.
So in that case, you'll maintain
a list of these
delegate objects.
Over to the fragment side.
So here, we get a handle
to the activity in
onActivityCreated, which is
the earliest that you have
access to a functioning
activity object.
And when we get that activity,
we know what kind of activity
created us.
And so we cast it.
We cast it to do a controller
and then that allows us to
register ourselves with it.
And after that, we are done.
We don't have to know who
the controller is.
We're decoupled from it.
If the controller needs to do
something while we're still
up, it will call perform an
action with some arbitrary
information.
And at that point, we can change
our internal state, or
we can change our UI,
or whatever else
that we need to do.
We also need to deregister.
And since onActivityCreated
doesn't have an
onActivityDestroyed because
the activity actually goes
away much later, we do this
cleanup in onDestroy.
So in onDestroy, we find
out our controller.
And then we deregister from it
so that it won't send us any
more events.
This kind of a method has
a lot of advantages.
Its robust through orientation
changes.
Its robust through activity
pause and start.
Because it registers
when it comes up.
And it deregisters
when it goes out.
It doesn't rely on keeping any
pointers because pointers can
get stale pretty quickly.
Finally, this let's the
framework, and the fragment
manager, do most of the
heavy lifting for you.
And this leads to
shorter code.
So this is a pattern for
fragment and activity
communication.
SCOTT: I don't really think
of this as communication.
VIKRAM: Yeah, you're right.
Two way communication is
kind of challenging.
SCOTT: It's challenging because
mobile networks are
slow and expensive.
Not everyone has unlimited
high speed data.
And so it helps to keep your
network usage in check.
In addition to turning on the
network less frequently, you
need to do less with it once the
connection is established.
So let's look at what
Gmail does.
Gmail tries to limit total
data usage by the app.
First, we let users configure
what gets synced, and how much
mail we sync.
This is great for users to set
up a new device because, by
default, they only get 30 days
of mail from their inbox.
If they have filters set up to
move noncritical mail out of
their inbox, this means they
don't get all their mail sent
to their device.
And this saves space
and data usage.
As you can see in this case, the
user has set up filters to
remove particularly
annoying email.
Gmail may offered gigabytes of
storage, but you probably
don't want it all
on your device.
Also, you can see this user
has set up filters to move
non-work email out
of their inbox.
Users loves such
customization.
It makes them more productive,
reduces data transfer, and
improves battery life.
To further reduce unnecessary
data usage, we don't do any
timed pulling.
The server sends us a very short
message, which you can
do with Google Cloud
Messaging.
And that tells us there's
new data.
At this point, we
begin a sync.
On this slide is an example of
some of the client code for
Cloud Messaging.
In the first part, we register
for Cloud Messaging.
The registration ID needs to be
sent to your server at some
point because it's
used to direct
messages to your device.
The second part is an example
of a GCM intent service.
You do need to use that name, as
other classes depend on it.
In this case, whenever we
receive a message, we just
request a sync.
For a more in depth
explanation, refer
to the GCM 2.0 talk.
VIKRAM: GCM 2.0.
Better than 1.0?
SCOTT: Twice as good.
When we do anything in the
background, we use an intent
service it receives an intent
and then spawns a background
thread to let us do any
long running tasks,
like syncing mail.
And then it shuts down
when it's complete.
This is much better than having
a service that is
continuously running but is just
sitting there, waiting
for tasks, and isn't active.
However, one intent service
can only have
one background thread.
So if you need to have multiple
tasks running
simultaneously, you'll need
multiple intent services, or a
custom implementation.
We only want to retrieve
changes since
the previous sync.
So we keep track of the server's
timestamp the last
time it was successful.
The next time we sync, we
send this time stamp
back up to the server.
And it only sends us since
the previous sync.
Finally, some network transfer
may be deferred until a Wi-Fi
connection is established.
So in Gmail, we allow you to
automatically download
attachments when on Wi-Fi.
Other common cases are podcast
clients allowing you to
download podcasts on Wi-Fi and
social networking apps
deferring photo uploads
until you're on Wi-Fi.
This improves the performance of
the device and the overall
user experience.
But really, the biggest trick
is to be selective
about what you sync.
The less you sync, the less
code you run, and the less
network and battery you use.
So be careful about what
you sync and try to
minimize data transfer.
But once you have this
new data, you need
to notify the user.
Notification should be shown
for critical new content,
something a user may want to
take immediate action on.
Everyone knows what
a notification is.
But here's an example.
VIKRAM: Wow, nice notification,
Scott.
SCOTT: Thank you.
But while it looks great, it
doesn't give the user any
valuable information, or at
least nothing valuable or
critical to the user.
Moreover, there's no immediate
action the user can take.
Such notifications are annoying,
so don't make them.
You want to present enough
information to the user so
they only open the app
if there is something
they need to do.
You need to give them
enough information
to make this decision.
If it's valuable, and it needs
immediate action, the user
will open the app.
Otherwise, the user knows they
don't need to open the app.
And they can just dismiss
the notification.
If you give them enough
information so that they don't
open the app only to close it
right away when they realized
there's nothing to do, then
you've created a great
notification.
Gmail uses several distinct
types of notifications.
When the notification is
collapsed, or on ICS, we try
to present as much information
as possible in the limited
space that we have.
For single message, we display
the sender name, the photo,
the subject of the message, and
the account or label name,
along with the number
of unread messages.
When there are multiple new
messages, we show you how many
are new, the account or
label name, and the
number of unread messages.
But you can do better
than this.
With expandable notifications,
you can present the user with
a lot more information.
And with notification actions,
you can let them take specific
actions straight from
the notification.
VIKRAM: Yeah, in this example,
you can reply to yourself,
tell yourself how awesome
your notification was.
SCOTT: I do that all the time.
VIKRAM: Good.
SCOTT: On Jelly Bean, when
there's only one new message,
we present you with all the
same information from the
collapsed notification.
We also show as much of the
message as possible.
We do this using big text style,
which is an inner class
of notification compat.
We also give you two
notification actions.
So in my example, I can read the
entire message, and I can
archive it right from the
notification without ever
having to enter the app.
Remember, with notification
actions, your goal is to allow
the user to do something quick
right from the notification
without having to
enter the app.
So with archive, you don't
have to enter the app.
And with reply, we bypass a
screen in the app and take you
right to writing a reply, rather
than just into the
message, where you don't
have to click reply.
In an app like Gmail, there's
a lot of actions you might
want to take on a message.
So we made the most common
actions the default.
But we also allow for some
minimal customization based on
user preferences.
When there are multiple new
messages, we show you a list
of senders and subjects using
inbox style, which is also
available in notification
compat.
This lets the user decide if
there's any new messages that
warrants opening the app
for further action.
With all notifications, when you
swipe it away to dismiss
it, we mark those messages as
having been seen so that you
never get a new notification
for the same message.
If another message were to come
in after dismissing this
one, it would be the only one
in the notification, rather
than just adding to the list
and showing you three.
So to summarize, you want to
create a notification so good
that the user does not have to
enter the app unless there's
immediate action they
need to take.
If a simple action can be
offered, it should be
presented right from
the notification.
And only show one notification
per event.
Don't show duplicate
notifications
for the same thing.
It's also a good idea to let
a user configure their
notification settings.
VIKRAM: Seems kind of strange
that we're asking these
developers that users shouldn't
enter their app.
SCOTT: Well, the user doesn't
really care if they're using
the app or just a
notification.
To them, it's all the
interactions with the app.
VIKRAM: Yeah, you're right in
that once the user does enter
your app, you want to make
your app more fluid.
Because you already
have the data.
You've already done the sync.
You've showing the
notification.
So let's take a look at
how we do some of
that using the loaders.
Loaders are this framework
mechanism to generate data off
the UI thread and to return
them on the UI thread.
Gmail and email use loaders
extensively.
We use them for all of our
native data types, which, for
Gmail and email, is accounts,
and folders, and
conversations.
Loaders are the easiest
way to obtain data
off a content provider.
The API is generally enough
that you could write an
loaders for your use case.
Though in most cases,
you would probably
use a cursor loader.
The cursor loader performs
a content provider
query of the UI thread.
And then it returns
a cursor over the
data on the UI thread.
Let's look at an example.
So that's the example
of a loader.
Scott, what's this?
SCOTT: Isn't this a loader?
It's the first result I
got in image search.
VIKRAM: I don't know, man.
How would we know?
We're all software
engineers here.
To us, everything's
gray boxes.
SCOTT: Oh, like this.
VIKRAM: Yeah, like this.
And this crowd understands these
boxes just like we do.
This is roughly what the
loader looks like.
On the left is the UI thread.
And your interface to the
loader is initLoader.
You call initLoader, and then
you get a call back called
onCreateLoader.
And that's where you create your
cursor loader, or really
any kind of loader.
And the cursor loader will go
off in the background thread.
And it will do this content
provider query.
The box is supposed to look big
because it's supposed to
be heavy, and hit your
disk, and basically
slow the system down.
But you don't care because it's
in the background thread.
When the query is done, it'll
call the call back
onLoadFinished, which has a
cursor over that information.
One trick that we've learned is
to implement all of these
callbacks in a separate
object.
One way you might be doing this
already is to have an
activity or a fragment implement
these callbacks.
But then, when you do that, if
you have to relocate the
callbacks everywhere somewhere
else, you have to grab all
these callbacks and put them
in a different object.
And that's cumbersome.
So let's look at an example
with all of these ideas.
So here, in onCreateLoader,
we create a loader.
The ID is somewhat arbitrary.
It's kind of like a
Unix file handle.
You want to the same ID
for the same unit of
data, in some sense.
In this case, we have an integer
called Folder Loader
because we will only make folder
objects out of these.
And the advantage of keeping
the same ID is that if you
rotate the device, and if you
have a loader running, you'll
get back a cursor over the
previous data right away.
So there won't be any lag if the
user rotates the device.
We use this a lot in Gmail.
In both onCreate loader
and onLoadFinished, we
check the loader ID.
We want to make sure that this
was really a folder that was
being created.
And then we do all
of our stuff.
But you might want the same
sort of logic if you have
other loaders, like a
conversation loader, or a list
loader, or whatever.
The information that's passed to
the loader to get the load
started is all in that bundle
called arguments in
onCreateLoader.
And that's also a really
good pattern.
Try to pass all of you loader
information in the arguments
as opposed to having globals
because that allows you to
relocate this class called
folder loads
in a different place.
At sometime in the future, when
the data is ready, you
get a call to onLoad finished.
It has cursor right there.
You can go ahead and use it.
It was created off
the UI thread.
So there was no lag.
You might also get this onLoader
reset, which happens
if the data goes away.
And so you want to reset your
state, forget your reference
to the cursor if you
had maintained one.
So let's look at how we
use this call back.
Again, using this call back
is really simple.
We create a callback
object in Gmail.
And he always make
final objects.
And we make them final because
they tend to have very minimal
state associated with them.
So it helps if it's tied in with
the object that is your
activity, or your fragment.
When you need data, you
call this method,
happily called needData--
it's kind of clear
what it does.
And we pass it a single URI,
which is the thing that you
want to query from.
And we past that URI
inside the bundle.
So it's not a global.
It's passed in the bundle
so that the loader call
back can get at it.
We give it the call
back object.
We give it the bundle.
That's the arguments.
And then we give it that unique
ID for the loader.
So this works really well
for data that's
created from loaders.
In Gmail, and in general, you
have these cases where you
create an entire object from
a row of a cursor.
And when that starts to happen,
when you do have a one
to one mapping between a cursor
row and an object, you
can actually do much better.
You can create entire objects
off the UI thread.
And the idea is fairly
straightforward.
You have this cursor loader
that's already doing the
content provider query
of the UI thread.
What you want is, you want
that thing to create the
objects in advance, before
returning the results.
Objects that know that this is
a special cursor can get at
the object reference that
was previously created.
And whatever you return here
will continue being a cursor.
So things that don't even know
that this is a special cursor
can call usual cursor
of methods.
So let's see how this is done.
This is our object cursor.
It creates objects
of type T. And it
extends a cursor wrapper.
So it's real, qualified cursor,
except that has two
special methods.
It has a method called getModel
which will return
objects of type T which were
created off the UI thread.
And that's the important
point.
That's why we're doing
all of this.
And the second method is
fillCache, which allows you
populate these objects
of the UI thread.
The loader itself subclasses
async task loader.
Our sample app has the
full implementation.
And the async task loader, in
the implementation of loading
background, it does the content
provider query, which
it's doing already.
And that returns a cursor
called hidden.
It's called hidden because
we never return it.
What we do with that cursor is
that we create an object
cursor from it, along with a
factory object that knows how
to create these T objects from
every row of the cursor.
And then we fill the
cache right away.
This means that your entire
cursor is going to get fed,
and the objects will get created
off the UI thread.
So since this runs in the
loading background, this is
all happening off the UI thread,
the object creation is
not slowing down your UI.
Let's going to a consumer
of this loader.
You can see the general
consumer pattern here.
We have the same class,
which implements
all the loader callbacks.
It's still called handle loads,
so it looks the same,
except that in onLoadFinished,
instead of getting back a
cursor, now it gives back an
object cursor of type T.
And in this case, we
have an object
called a big heavy object.
It suggests that it takes
a long time to create.
But we don't have to create
it on the UI thread.
Now, we can do data.getModel
because, now, the object's
already been created for you.
As before, to use these
callbacks, we create a final
callback object.
And in this case, rather than
doing a need data, I have
onCreate, where I initialize
this LOADER_BIG_HEAVY, because
it's not a folder anymore.
It's to a big, heavy loader.
So it's got a different idea.
And then, just like before, we
have a URI that we shove in
the bundle, and we have
a callback object.
So this looks for data that
you already have.
Scott, do you know what we do
for downloading large data off
the internet?
SCOTT: Large data loads need
a different mechanism.
So let's look at what
Gmail does.
So many apps download large
objects from the network.
There are quite a few developers
who valiantly try
to write their own
download service.
VIKRAM: Yeah, I know.
My download service had
a few minor bugs--
some crashes, some hangs,
data loss--
SCOTT: Yeah, a couple
of harmless bugs.
So we ended up using an
excellent service called
DownloadManager.
DownloadManager is a service
to download data from the
network in a robust manner it
works on Gingerbread and
above, so it's available
nearly everywhere.
If you need to support Froyo
and earlier, consider using
your own implementation on
those older versions.
Use DownloadManager on later
versions where it's available.
This way, any updates to the
framework will benefit your
app running on Gingerbread
or later.
VIKRAM: Oh my goodness,
my eyes.
That looks ugly.
SCOTT: Users can tell when you
use your own implementation
because the download
notification often looks horrible.
Many are themed for Gingerbread
or earlier, and
they look really out of place
on the hollow theme, as you
can see here.
Using DownloadManager
is really simple.
In fact, the code to download
a file is just one line.
When the download completes, an
intent is sent to your app
to let your app know.
DownloadManager works best when
you have a single large
file to download.
VIKRAM: Wow, just one line.
I hope these guys aren't being
paid by the number of lines of
code they write.
SCOTT: Well, good developers
like everyone in the audience,
will probably write very
detailed comments
above that one line.
But if you're really concerned
about increasing your lines of
code, you can take a look
at the request object.
It lets you specify
lots of options.
So here, we create a new
request to specify some
settings for the download.
First, you said which network
types to allow.
And I like Wi-Fi because
it's usually free.
And we're providing it to
all of you right now.
Then we set whether to allow
metered or roaming
connections.
And I've disallowed these
because they may
cost the user extra.
Then we said where
to save the file.
Note that download manager
requires write access to this
URI, so you can't just pass
in a file path your app's
internal data directory.
Then we set the text to display
in the notification.
And we set the notification
visibility.
You can set it to show up only
while downloading, only when
complete, both, or neither.
VIKRAM: Scott, what's
VISIBILITY_VISIB
LE_NOTIFY_COMPLETED?
SCOTT: It sets the visibility
to be visible.
And it will notify you when the
download has completed.
VIKRAM: OK.
SCOTT: An intent is
broadcast when the
notification is clicked.
So your app can handle and
take the user directly to
their downloaded content.
And finally, you can set whether
to show the download
in the system downloads UI,
which lets the user managed
all of their downloaded content
across all their apps.
So you have a lot of control
over the download request if
you need it.
DownloadManager has a lot of
functionality and will ensure
that your app properly handles
intermittent connections and
network switching that's common
on mobile devices.
It will provide a much better
experience for your users than
most custom implementations.
Users typically get a new mobile
device every two years.
And they love apps that maintain
their settings.
In Gmail, we back up certain
preferences to the cloud so
that when a user upgrades to
new device, these settings
restore themselves.
Users love it since they don't
have to reconfigurable
everything.
The backup and restore process
is transparent to the users,
so all they should realize is
that the app is already
configured the way
they want it.
From a high level, an app can
tell the backup manager that
there is new that there's
new data to back up.
At some point in the future,
backup manager will query your
app asking for this data.
And then it'll send
it to the cloud.
When a new app is installed, the
system checks if there's
any data backup and
will automatically
restore it for your app.
You can also manually request to
restore operation, but this
should not necessary.
You know, this actually reminds
me of something that
happened back in Canada.
VIKRAM: Canada, eh?
Tell me about it.
SCOTT: It was a typical winter
day in Ottawa, so minus 40.
I left my phone in my
car for a few hours.
And when I came back, it was
not in a very good state.
After fiddling around with it
for a bit, I was able to get
it to boot up, sort of.
But it's said the battery was
almost dead, even though it
should've been fully charged.
And the touch screen didn't
really respond.
VIKRAM: Oh man.
SCOTT: I really wish I had cloud
backup and restore then
because I could have
just switched to a
new phone right away.
Instead, I had to wait
for mine to thaw.
But back to cloud backup.
So to start, you need to add a
reference in your manifest to
your backup agent.
This lets the system know
which component of your
application will handle the
backup and restore process.
VIKRAM: Looks pretty simple.
SCOTT: Yeah, I tried to get
them to make the API more
complicated, so I'd have more
to talk about, but they
wouldn't listen to me.
And unfortunately, the Java
the side is just as easy.
If all you need to do is backup
shared preferences, or
other simple files, you just
extend a backup agent helper
and an onCreate, add a few
backup helpers that specify
which shared preferences and
files to back up, and this
will handle everything
else for you.
If you need to do something more
complicated, you can back
up and restore byte arrays,
but this requires that you
implement a lot more code.
So here, we implement the
onBackup method to back up a
name and a signature.
The onRestore method is similar,
but you have to
deserialize the byte array into
the data you require.
Keep in mind that the backup
service should not be used to
synchronize data
across devices.
It will not work for this.
VIKRAM: Scott, I just realized
why people hate Java.
I mean, look at those names.
Byte array, output stream,
helper thingy, doer, maker.
SCOTT: Well, I don't know.
Personally, I think those names
aren't long enough.
We need to add some factory,
and delegate,
and other fancy words.
But since we're on the subject,
let's look at some
source code organization and
some helpful libraries.
To bring your application to
more devices, the support
library is extremely useful.
It contains a lot of framework
APIs backboarded around on
Donut and later.
This lets you use fragments,
loaders, view pagers, and
other new and useful classes in
your app, even if your app
runs on devices running versions
of Android from
before these classes existed.
Gmail doesn't yet use the
support activity fragment or
loader classes, but it uses
view pager, notification
compat, task stack builder,
and a few others.
The benefit of using classes
from the support library, even
if your app only runs on ICS
and up, like Gmail, is that
the support library may contain
bug fixes and new
features that are not available
on older versions of
Android, like ICS.
Using components from the
support library allows your
app to take advantage of the
latest platform features,
bringing a lot of them to older
devices and degrading
gracefully where it can't.
It also means that if the
support library were ever
updated to offer more features
on Donut you wouldn't have to
make any significant changes
to your app to take
advantage of them.
To use the support library
classes, it's usually a simple
matter of changing your imports
with minor class and
method name differences.
So here we have an example.
As you can see, the imports
change to the
support library versions.
Activity becomes
FragmentActivity.
And Notification becomes
NotificationCompat.
It's pretty simple.
Method names also change, so
instead of getFragmentManager,
you have to call
getSupportFragmentManager.
Support But it's not
complicated at all.
As I mentioned earlier, it's
a very good idea to use the
support library wherever
you can.
Viki, we're you going to say
something funny here?
VIKRAM: Yeah, that thing
we talked about?
Last night I was thinking it's
just not funny enough, so I
took it out.
SCOTT: But now they'll never
hear the story but your
grandmother and the
trampoline.
VIKRAM: So some things
are best left unsaid.
SCOTT: Some other things we
aren't exactly going to share
is actual source code from
the Gmail application.
VIKRAM: Yeah, we talked
to our manager.
I don't think we were
convincing enough.
We just weren't persuasive.
SCOTT: That's OK.
You can download source
code for some of the
components we use.
The Android open source project
contains two such
components.
The pretty UI for senders in
Gmail that lets you select
recipients is called chips.
This library is used in Gmail
calendar and messaging.
It lets you select a contact
by typing in a
name or email address.
Once you have a contacts
selected, you can easily
specify which email address
you want to use.
As a developer, you can treat
the main component,
RecipientEditTextView, as
a normal text view.
Just populate it with a comma
separated list of email
addresses, or use the appended
method, as shown on this
slide, and it will resolve the
contacts in the chips.
When you read the text out of
it, you get a string that can
be tokenized to give
you a list of
names and email addresses.
The source code for
chips is in the
framework's EX directory.
Photo viewer is a pre-built
activity for viewing
a gallery of photos.
It contains scrolling
support, zooming,
and some other features.
Launching it is fairly simple,
as you can see here.
Gmail uses it so that if you
receive a message with image
attachments, we can present them
all to you in a gallery
format, rather than sending you
into the Gallery app for
each individual image.
For basic gallery browsing, you
have to set up a content
provider that implements
photo contract.
This provider must return names,
URIs, and some other
important items for
the gallery.
The source code for photo viewer
is in frameworks opt.
Google Play services is an APK
in a static library that you
can use to add Google-specific
features to your application.
The APK is automatically
installed on devices running
Froyo or higher that have
the Play Store.
It contains the bulk
of the library.
The static library is built in
your application and lets you
talk to the Play Services APK.
One of the main benefits of
Play services over other
libraries is that when certain
new features and bug fixes are
available, we can push those out
to every device, and your
app will automatically benefit
without even having to release
your own update.
For more details on Play
services, refer to the What's
New in Google Play
Services session.
To integrate Play Services into
your app, you need to
build against the library
project and reference it from
your application.
At runtime, you need to perform
a check to make sure
that a new enough version of
Play Services is installed.
If not, you can use one of the
provided dialogues to prompt
the user to download
or update it.
Gmail only uses Play Services
if it's available, and we
never prompt the user.
So that's another option if
this functionality isn't
strictly necessary for
your application.
Google Play Services has many
features you can use.
The games API was
just launched.
There's Google+ integration,
some new location APIs,
authentication, maps,
and more.
These were all discussed in
great detail in other
sessions, so they will
not be covered here.
VIKRAM: Yeah, that's a
lot of functionality.
Could we give a quick overview
of what Gmail uses here?
SCOTT: Sure.
Gmail uses photosphere support
from Play Services.
When you receive a Photosphere
attachment, you can view it
within the message, rather than
having to open it up in
the gallery and view
it from there.
To display a Photosphere, you
need to connect to a Panorama
client and load the Panorama
info by passing
in the photo URI.
This will return an intent to
you which you can use to start
an activity to view
the Photosphere.
To help you implement Photo
Viewer, and other features we
talked, about here's the link
with our sample app.
VIKRAM: All right, we'll have
this link later as well.
So we've talked about a lot.
Here's a slide of everything
with links.
SCOTT: What?
VIKRAM: Yeah, you're right.
This is not what we want
to leave you with.
This is not a talk about
isolated components
that you can use.
The idea is a lot
more high level.
The idea is to recognize what
the framework makes
available to you.
Be aware of its functionality.
Make the framework do most of
the heavy lifting for you.
The idea is to fit the system
well and to understand the
standard way of doing things.
So you do less, and
you focus on what
makes your users happy.
On behalf of your users,
thank you for making
those awesome apps.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT: Thank you.
We'll be taking questions
in office hours.
And please review our session.
You can use the Google I/O app
to do that, or scan one of the
QR codes around the room.
VIKRAM: Yeah, even if you
have to say how bad
it was, it's fine.